all right Gigi
Gigi where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
um I'm from California but I pretty much
grew up everywhere
um we lived pretty much in the valley
and then Orange County then my mom got
divorced and we moved like to this
Austin Crenshaw area south central
Canada yeah like uh the more I guess the
rolling 60s area
what was your chocolate like
um I was actually
I had multiple stepfathers so with each
stepfather kind of came a new thing
um I had an original called my original
father
um
he passed away though when I was three
from AIDS complications it was my
mother's first husband he's the man who
gave me his last name he's not my
biological father
but their family was well to do I grew
up very well and like the West Adams
area
initially with them and then my mom got
remarried to a Muslim man
and um
I will stay with him things changed uh
probably for the better in ways that I
didn't understand at the time but they
were still like there was a lot of
things in the household that were off
but he
I won't ever say it was because of him
really because I think the little
structure that I do have to this day is
because of him
any abuse in your childhood
um
yes ones that I can place and ones that
I can't
um some initiated by myself even as a
child
which I've come to terms with older as
I've become older
things occur girls grow fast in the hood
don't they
um yeah
um yeah you'll
I think
it comes to you whether or not you used
to be playing with dolls but men are
talking about things to you or I think
that's how that goes or some kind of
trauma comes in and then that changes
your whole mind but age were you when
you lost your virginity
um I think I was just about to turn 16
or yeah about to turn 16. oh that's not
that not a control oh yeah I know I kind
of kept I think because of the influence
of my stepfather the Islam uh kind of
mildly kicked in but at that time my mom
had I divorced him or separated from him
so I pretty much was able to do what I
wanted or was yeah wasn't underneath his
thumb what kind of girl were you in high
school
um initially I was an honor roll student
at Westchester High School and before it
was over I was pretty much hanging out
with the
other
children that were not focused on school
so I kind of went from a kid that was
scared to even go into the cafeteria for
fear of the popular kids and
other children because I was kind of the
nerdy child and didn't have that many
friends and I would hang out and do my
actually do my homework
during the breaks because I was like I
think anti-social too because of
probably my upbringing
so I always had fear of other people
probably a lot more than I would
probably can accept still to this day
but uh yeah then I got to hanging out
with the bad kids and that's what that
was
you graduated no I I'm actually kind of
got kicked out
um of Westchester about my first part of
my 11th
of the 11th grade
and what'd you do after that
oh just hung out
with the neighborhood kids pretty much
um
moved around I mostly probably had some
kind of adult boyfriend who probably was
taking care of me
um but probably just moved around looked
at my grandmother's house worked here
and there a regular job
how'd you get introduced to the
prostitution hmm
the first time I really did it it was um
it was weird I had a boyfriend who was
in jail
and my mother had got upset about the
phone bill
and I kept accepting his phone calls and
she was pretty much telling me I had to
get out or pay the phone bill
and um
somehow yeah I knew from just men just
in my being a child and it offered me
money and stuff and I always knew that
there was I had a cousin actually it was
a pimp
so I knew Sunset existed so I literally
just rode the bus out to Sunset
and um
attempted to prostitute across from the
7-11 across from the Zankou Chicken that
I'd gone to every day as a child
um yeah I tried to prostitute there and
actually the first guy ever picked me up
I explained to him that I was that he
would be my first person ever and he
basically gave me some money and put me
right back out his car
and gave me his phone number and told me
yeah he wouldn't do the date with me
but you continued
oh yeah I needed the money so I stayed
there and so I got some money
um yeah
you've been doing it how long
I think I was 18 the first time I ever
did it
and then I kind of just shunned it out
I didn't start doing it again until I
started dancing I became a dancer and
then when I saw other girls and how much
money they were making I only was going
home with 150 dollars that's when I
couldn't do it anymore and you realize
even working at a strip club you could
make money yeah when I'm going home with
just max three 400 and I'm seeing them
just
billfold full of money and I just know
the only difference is that they're
doing something when they go to the back
and I'm not
and I at the time I think I was homeless
probably sleeping in the car
so
yeah it was a choice that I made
inside pretty much but I'd also met an
older man at the time
and he was the first man to ever like
really helped me he and the club
actually asked me what was one thing he
could do for me
and he was the first person to give me
well he brought me my first pair of
implants
and he was extremely older man he also
used to be a pimp in his younger day
but um
with that I had told myself if I deal
with this man I'm pretty much telling
myself
so I remember sitting in my motel room
and telling myself like I'm sick of
living in motels I'm sick of paying for
them every day
I'm sick of this am I going to and I
just
went through the whole thing with myself
in my room by the time I woke up in the
morning I knew that that's what I was
going to do I at least was gonna go with
him
and then
he wasn't going to expect he didn't
expect me to prostitute anything but in
my mind I knew that if I was going with
this man older man I knew basically that
I was going into something for money so
that was my first rule accepting that I
was gonna do this to survive
you've worked with temps since then oh
no I've only paid one man ever to help
me when it got kind of thick on Figaro
because I when I first would go to like
Western and Figueroa
um I was scared so uh and then I think I
had one incident or something and then I
paid a guy to just start coming out
there or if I called him to please show
up
mm-hmm so you're a renegade is what they
call it yes pretty much my cousin if
anybody's flag I fly under my my cousin
that was passed uh he was a pimp so if
anybody's flag I flew under I flew
underneath his flag
and drugs are part of your life oh no
marijuana
um is basically it I was
if anything would kill me would have
been alcohol
but I don't currently drink alcohol too
much I think
I actually have a really weird immune
deficiency that I think came from
drinking alcohol or PTSD or something
it's called achalasia and it's where
your esophagus no longer works
and I have zero motility in my esophagus
and I think it came from years of
alcoholism when I first
even being a juvenile I drink heavily
and I knew that that probably would kill
me
um the only things I've tried is sure
maybe three times in e-pilled twice and
had horrible reactions off of them every
time I said for the first time
I think because of traumas I can't take
real drugs at all I just freak out
immediately like the Grim sleepers come
in
and you have your own apartment or you
stay in motels I have a trailer
currently I've bought a trailer that I
live in uh it's off uh well currently
I'm living down like in Gardena in the
trailer with the rest of the community
that's over there off of Redondo Beach
but the sheriff is pushing us out
literally on the 21st so
um yeah I got to figure out where I'm
gonna take my trailer and move it to do
you have kids I have one daughter she is
20 what is there 23 this year 33
you're older than I thought you were oh
yeah I'm 41. you're 41. yeah a lot of
people get kind of taken it back by that
told me you're 23 and I would have
bought it
thank you yeah people can I get tickets
like what yeah no I was born in 81. are
you
did you raise your daughter
and okay my daughter was uh kind of but
no I mean she was given to my mother
through Ken Gap so I still was able to
be in my daughter's life but my mother
was the person who um was in full
control basically of the situation
in your work what kind of hours now just
whenever you need money or do you have
oh yeah whenever I need money generally
um I tried not to I've always been one
foot in one foot out I think because of
uh
maybe my faith or
uh yeah I've always been I'm very aware
of how many sins I'm racking up even if
I can't remember everybody's name I'm
still
I'm consciously aware of the sin I'm in
and I'm I know that I'm probably already
overhead and probably will never get out
of it but I just am not willing to
accept it fully that I'm just yeah so
I've always been just enough to get what
I want or what I need
but I just I'm not doing it just to make
money or just Brack up a bank account
that I'm not doing you're doing it to
survive yes basically absolutely
and I and that's where I'm kind of about
where people
have something to say about it
I kind of feel like if you're feeding
other people or just taking care of
yourself and that's all you're doing it
for like
there's no I'm not saying it's sinless
but there's really probably
lessen it than a lawyer
had bad experiences out there
um that's better bad dates yeah like oh
from the tricks
what's up
um
what is the most crazy thing I probably
have ever oh yeah
um
I guess there's a guy on Western that
they're saying is like a multi-rapist or
two of them that they've done like a
police
they did a loose thing about it but I
believe that I wanted his victims too
because they told me I was but I'm not
quite sure
and um yeah I did a date with him he
pulled out a pistol
Lily was chuckling my cousin had just
been killed maybe two weeks prior so I
kind of when it happened I just kind of
just checked it off like I can just
check this one off like because I've had
so many things happen to me in my life
and been raped many ways
um I've never at gunpoint so that was
just like check the box and I actually
was just chuckling when he pulled it out
I think he was in shock that like I
didn't I didn't I was saying okay babe
you want me to do it like this and
I think he was taking it back he was
couldn't even use flagellate I think
because it wasn't working out that
wasn't the reaction he wanted to get
turned on so therefore it didn't work
and um
I think that worked out for me and um I
think also
speaking to him prior
I think helped me out
um because he started asking me
questions before he did this to me and
I just told him the truth it's like oh
no I'm just here because I have to take
care of my kid and I have a very father
that's passed and no it's not correct
and I think from that I don't think he
went Full Throttle on me like he was I
could kind of see a couple times he was
just kind of leaning back
just trying to like take in his
situation like what is really going on
here so but I mean completely compliant
and it worked out for me I believe
staying a lady will work out for you
even when it's gone wrong I totally
believe it if
Nothing Stops them at least maybe their
conscience will stop them from hurting
another girl so just stay a lady even
when it's gone wrong if it's gonna I
mean unless he's really killing you bite
him or something but you know fight back
but it's best to just try to stay a lady
be robbed
get it taken you're still alive
but best to stay a lady because it would
probably turns out better for you
and yeah to survive yeah being a lady
really does work people discounted and
people men take it from you and I will
admit that I know I've had it taken from
me quite a few times I haven't always
been a lady
it's very hard to retain it and hold it
and hold on to it here
but you've got to because it is like a
survival tool here
despite the fact that you know you might
get
knocked around a little
what kind of guys do you typically pick
up black men are extremely attractive to
me I think the black she is being skinny
with these chichis and kind of black
Barbie thing hits them and uh usually
when I it depends on the area I think I
do well with all people to be completely
honest I don't have a particular group
of men I think they're like me I think
all men like me or care for me so I find
I'm fig I have a lot of black men of
thought for me which is supposed to be
iffy about but of course and
um ladman of course are there but when
I'm like in Orange County it's you know
Latin Caucasian men or something up
there there but yeah same thing I think
it's just wherever's there
but I do find I kind of get swarmed by
even The Pimps at times they even tell
me they're out of pocket they just want
to talk to me and so I'll be like okay
uh you're not supposed to do this so
yeah that kind of stuff how does this
work affect you emotionally I think
because I'm truthful with myself and
with my relationship with God I'm
truthful about it the emotional part is
probably just the fact I put myself
through all this I think it's a hurtful
part taking responsibility for hurting
yourself
I think it's the most hurtful part of it
for me because I know I'm smarter I know
I could have made better choices I know
that something in me doesn't want to
work a regular job and I don't want to
be around people like I'm not functional
on that level intimately yes
but as far as groups and women and
certain things I just know that I'm just
like it doesn't work I don't mix well
because I'm
I think because I've been so long in a
subculture when I have to be like
mainstream in certain things I just you
can yeah I just and I'm and I don't care
to fit in either so I think that's kind
of another thing about me I'm okay with
who I am would you consider yourself
addicted to this lifestyle
I think if anything I'm addicted to the
fact because I grew up maybe
with a feeling of not being attractive
I'm addicted to
being told I am I think the confirmation
I even had my ex-husband tell me that he
said you like doing this because it
makes you feel like you're pretty you
were told you're not attractive oh
growing up I was teased we were poor so
I was teased quite frequently at school
oh thank you
thank you for saying that and I know I
have to learn how to tell people thank
you because I've actually read books
about myself
and I've learned that I kind of just in
and about one area if I even do I even
consciously am I even consciously
accepting that when people tell it to me
I think it's like when someone tells you
good morning or something
I took it just said it's like if someone
told me good morning have a good day
just like something you say
just to be polite
and um
it's taken a while and I think still to
this day
for me to truly get that in my head
because I didn't have a mother that
enforced that I didn't come from a
family that did
so um
yeah I come up I grew up in a family
full of half breeds and I'm the only one
practically with the full black father
and uh coarse hair so I grew up
believing that no
there was something different about me
I had a grandfather who called me the
colored girl
and I love this grandfather too so this
is a man I love to death and I would
give my arm to bring back right now
um
your mother's a half breeding my
grandfather is Caucasian I don't know
what exactly but the ancestry.com says
Irish from what I'm spend the cup is 30
for me so I don't know where my mother
actually is because she has not spit in
the cup but uh I had a Caucasian
grandfather that used to tell my mixed
cousins go get the colored girl
and um yeah so for me a long time it was
an imprint that there was something
different about me than them or that
there was something wrong with me and I
think my mom even had it too
because I have a brother and he's darn
near White
and he was treated differently
so it's a shame how
often parents fail at building
self-worth in a child
yeah I think though
everything's learned
so I think that unless they learned it
then they're truly cruel
if they knew how to do it but if they
never were tied either then it's just
a sad situation this is just a cultural
thing in the hood that you just don't
no one no one ever learns how to build
self-worth in their children
I
I believed it yeah if um
I always thought of like a more
Reflections everybody's a reflection of
everybody so it's almost like how you
treat them it's like a mirror so
whatever it is you don't like in
yourself
whatever that mirror thing in them so
like how Africans and Latins are blacks
and Mexicans are we're literally mirror
images of each other almost anything
that you say about the other one the
other culture has the same thing going
on so it's a self-hatred
so when you see it in somebody else all
the things you don't like about yourself
then you don't like them and I've also
felt since I've had a child myself the
one thing that incites me the most about
my daughter are the things that she does
that are like me that I don't like about
me this is where I'm almost where I want
to break her neck
it's when she does the things and that I
know they're crucial things I don't like
about myself that make me a ugly person
and she does them those are things that
I really get me upset so I think it's
the mirror image thing for people and
they're
the lack of self-acceptance
and self-hatred
that um causes us to be ugly with each
other it's not really the other person I
think and that's where you really find
that the good people who are really good
those are that's why like it's not
they're so happy inside out with
themselves and everything else they can
actually
be human with the next person
you're very intelligent I have dissected
my life many ways because I had to
figure myself out and I had to figure
out
why people did things to me
I had to figure that I had to figure out
why this happened and I also had to
figure out why I did stuff
because I think even as a child I was
very smart
and I kind of had a revengeful mind and
there were things that happened to me
where
like I don't know to say this but
the prayer becomes a predator
so I'd be I was preyed upon and now I
became and I can say I became a predator
myself at certain points in my life
whether I was a child and prayed upon
other children or
whatever it was
um
it can develop that way if you do not
take care of it hone it recognize that
there's a beast or a demon in you or
something you must
get to that point where you know
yourself you have to just dissect it to
the Nano people actually told me
I think about stuff to the point where
I'm hurting myself
but I'm okay with that it's like think
about space you just get to thinking
about to think about to think about it
it's just all like for you just write
back to life what is this
though you know it's I think that that's
important to keep dissecting it too
you have figured out or anything if you
haven't figured it out
find a level of comfort in it
because I've done that with a lot of
traumas I just dissected them or relived
them over and over and over and over and
over and over and over to the point that
I'm comfortable with them now completely
traumatize you as much as no not at all
I've learned to work through them
completely
you had your life to live all over again
what would you have done differently
stayed in school
I would have
my mother she went to USC even though
she's distraught in the mind and
um
I think that that's my like on my
deathbed if I don't ever go to college
and get a degree
I don't think I'm gonna care about
anything else I've done my son or
anything else I think for me there are a
couple things I wanted to do before I
died I wanted to speak another language
play an instrument I wanted to graduate
from college these are three things that
were very important to me as a person
and as a human being like at eight
or growing up so if I didn't accomplish
those three things I care less about
anything else I've really done in life
and I'll just be disappointed
in myself
your biggest regret yeah School
I know that I could have
I should have been or I even know just
on another dimension that I exist that
person I really believe that she exists
somewhere else so I'm okay like where I
want to believe that the me exists in
another dimension I went to school and
I'm damn near running for president
what's your biggest fear
there's parts to it and it all has to
deal with afterlife I think one um
that the aliens are probably my real
lord
that all this stuff is fake
um
that when I die that's it
I will never see my dead family members
that I want to see so bad or dead people
I know
um and that that's really it
I think those are my big experience
those things actually wake me up in the
night
what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work men
you see men differently because of this
career
no I think I kind of already knew that
men were just grew up with all different
kinds of men so I kind of knew that
men are their own
people I don't why do I think about men
in general
I think
for a man to be a man it all is boiled
down to discipline
I believe that if there's any falter in
a man's lack of discipline
um or maybe upbringing we can throw that
one in and just on the side but
besides that about men
there's nothing wrong with the man and
stuff but they probably needs to be
disciplined or need to discipline
themselves or at least to recognize that
it needs some
but that's about it I think I don't look
at minutes so there's something wrong
with them I
actually many of the gist of my friends
I don't really have too many female
friends not that I yeah I find them more
untrustworthy so I'm yeah
that's interesting yeah
Gigi what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life you have some interesting thoughts
what
what does your brain not be angry
that you will you will kill yourself I
think the whole world right now is
killing itself on anger everybody's so
damn angry it's a great one everybody's
so damn angry they're gonna use drugs
they're gonna find excuse for their
anger
everybody's so angry stop being angry if
you can if you can if you can
find another emotion for it there are
other emotions like why are we all only
stuck on two emotions sad mad angry
there is hurt pitiful
disappointed depressed all of us refuse
to accept all these other emotions we
just want to go to mad or anger
like allow yourself other things allow
yourself to find yourself in these other
emotions
uh anger is going to kill you and all of
us actually
that's what I do believe believe that
everybody's anger is going to lead to
demise of all of us because eventually
probably one of these men with nukes is
gonna say you know what I don't like
your opinion so therefore there will be
no opinions and that's what we'll all be
at
all right Gigi thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you for having
me I'm so happy you're very interesting
thank you thank you